welcome to other famous friday
i believe that whatever goal you have
whatever obstacles in your way
somebody has already overcome it
somebody has already accomplished it
and the fastest way to achieve your
dream is to model the success of other
people who've already gone out and done
it
learn what worked for them and apply it
to your business so today's lesson is
set your own path
from accio marita who's the founder of
sony
now marita came from a long history of
sake brewers
he comes from a culture in japan that's
very traditional and his family was very
traditional
his family had been in the sake brewery
business since 1665
and he was the oldest son from his
father
and it was expected it was just expected
he would go into the sacred brewery
business as well
everybody in his family had always done
this this is the way it was always done
but he had to set his own path and he
said i don't want to go in the sake
brewery business
i want to go into the electronics
business and he set his own course
he continued modeling the strategy as he
went on to build his business
his first product was a flop it was too
expensive nobody wanted to buy it and he
needed a hit he needed something his
company wasn't
wasn't doing well wasn't taking off he
wasn't realizing his dreams
and then he came out with a transistor
radio and he got the dream order
okay this is a nothing burger company
and boulova which was a huge brand at
the time
offered to buy 100 000 transistor radios
from him
this was the dream the dream the huge
sale right here
the only catch was instead of it saying
sony on the radio it had to say bulova
and akio marita said no
no deal i'm going to set my own path
and he turned down the deal of a
lifetime
to do his own thing and it worked out
for him
and not only that not only thinking
about his family not only thinking about
his company he applied it to his country
at the time when he started sony after
after one of the world wars made in
japan
was seen as something that was was cheap
and
inferior and knockoff if you saw a
product that said made in japan
you would think it'd be really low
quality and he
had a goal to set his own path for his
nation
to turn made in japan into something
that meant quality
into a stamp of quality production
and it's worked if you look at a product
that says made in japan
versus another country if they're the
same price you're going to go for the
japanese one because you know that it's
made with quality he went so far as to
write a book
called made in japan to highlight that
process so
every step along the way in his life he
had to set his own path
he had to break free of tradition break
free of the rules that were being
imposed on him
he did in his family by saying no to the
sake business since 1665.
he said no to bulava who wanted to own
the branding
for the products that came out and he
said no to the traditional japanese
manufacturing process
that was poor quality and said i'm going
gonna put this country on my back
imagine the vision i'm gonna put this
country on my back and change the way
manufacturing is done you need to
set your own path for your business not
listen to
the traditional ways that things are
done not listen to the opinions of other
people who are trying to hold you where
you
are trying to hold you back from
becoming the entrepreneur that you can
be
set your own path believe in yourself
triumph
over the little man model success and
continue to believe
for those who watching like the video
subscribe to the channel you can see
more like it
thank you so much for watching i'll see
you soon
make sure to check out my newsletter
you're gonna love it
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say
evan carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun
inspiring and it's the only newsletter i
prioritize
and look forward to period